hi it's Michele from lab muffin beauty
science and today I'm talking about this
hair dryer the Panasonic eh na 98
Panasonic hair dryers are really popular
in Asia so it's really great to see them
launching in Australia I'm partnering
with Panasonic to talk about their
haircare technology and about my own
experience with this hair dryer one of
my main concerns about hair dryers is
how much heap damage they cause
especially since I have quite fragile
bleached hair this hair dryer is
designed to dry your hair while reducing
damage Panasonic's test groups found
that they had less split hens less frizz
and less scalp dryness after five weeks
of using this hair dryer one issue that
I've really noticed with my hair is that
on the first day after drying it feels
okay but then on the second and third
day it starts to get really dry and
crunchy especially in the ends I've been
using this hair dry for the last couple
of months and one of the things I've
really noticed is that on days 2 & 3 the
ends of my hair are much softer smoother
and much less snaggy even though I'm
using the same haircare products people
at work have been telling me that my
hair looks much less dry than before
as you probably know panasonic is well
known for their home appliances
especially their air conditioning
systems and they've incorporated some of
this technology into this hair dryer
it's the Nano air technology also found
in Paris onyx air conditioning systems
that seems to be responsible for the
decrease in visible hair damage split
hands and frizz nanni creates small
droplets of water using negative ions
these droplets are much smaller than
steam so they can get past the hair
cuticle but they're bigger than negative
ions so that they bring lots more
moisture into your hair essentially how
it works is the hair drag gathers water
from the air and passes high-voltage
through it to form these small nano e
droplets
the droplets can penetrate the hair
shaft and close the cuticle and so you
end up with moisturized hair the nano
droplets are also small enough to
moisturize your scalp skin as well as
the Nano II particles the hairdryer has
an intelligent sensor that adjusts the
temperature to prevent heat damage
there's a quick dried nozzle which
separates the strands of your hair so
that it dries faster without you having
to pump up the heat after I let my hair
sit in a microfiber towel for about 10
minutes it only takes 6 minutes to dry
my hair with this hairdryer and I have a
lot of hair this hair dryer has a
foldable handle so it's really
convenient for storage and there's a
sliding switch on the handle which makes
it really easy to switch between
different speeds there are some
different modes as well which you can
switch between using this button overall
I've been really impressed by this
Panasonic hairdryer this is the best
hair dryer I've used it drives my hair
quickly without it going brittle and it
leaves that feeling soft and smooth and
healthy if you want to find out more
about this hair dryer I've put some
links in the description or you can
check out Panasonic Australia's new
Instagram page which runs lots of
product giveaways